let's solve some rational equations
let's say i had 5
over
x minus 4
is equal to actually let me write it let
me scoot it over a little bit so let's
say i have 5
over
three
x minus four
is equal to
two over
x plus one so your first reaction might
be c's you know i've never seen this
before
i have x's in the denominators how to
actually solve this equation and the
easiest way to proceed and there's other
ways to do this is to try to multiply
both sides of this equation by
expressions that will get rid of these
x's in the denominator so if we multiply
both sides of the equation by x plus 1
if we multiply both sides of this
equation by x plus 1 it's going to get
rid of this x plus 1 in the denominator
and of course we have to do it to both
sides we can't just do it to one side
but we also want to get rid of this
expression right here so let's multiply
both sides of the equation by that
by three x
minus four so you're multiplying by
three x minus four on this side as well
so i'm just multiplying both sides of
this equation times this and times this
whatever i multiply on this side i also
have to do on this side now what's going
on what's what is it going to simplify
to well this 3x minus 4 is going to
cancel out with this 3x minus 4. so the
left-hand side is just going to be x
plus 1 times 5 or 5 times
x plus 1. and my right-hand side this x
plus 1 is going to cancel with that x
plus 1 is just going to equal 2 times 3x
minus 4. 2 times 3x
minus 4. and if you just look at it if
you didn't look at what we actually did
it looks like we did something called
cross multiplying when you have
something over something is equal to
something else over something else
notice the end product when we
multiplied both sides by both of these
expressions was
2 times 3x minus 4 2 times 2x minus 4 is
equal to 5 times x plus 1. so it looks
like we cross multiplied 5 times x plus
1 is equal to 2 times 3x minus 4. but
the reality is we didn't do anything new
we just multiplied both sides by this
expression and that expression but now
we just have a straight up linear
equation we can just simplify and solve
so the left hand side becomes five x
plus five just distribute the five is
equal to
six x
minus eight
now we could let's say we subtract 5x
from both sides
if we subtract 5x from both sides
the right hand side the left-hand side
just becomes a 5. the right-hand side we
are left with x minus eight
and now we could add eight to both sides
we add eight to both sides the left hand
side becomes thirteen
the right hand side is just an x and
we're done x is equal to 13
solves this equation you could even try
it out 5
over 3 times 13 is 39
39 minus 4 is 35
and this should be equal to 2
over
13 plus 1 or 14 and they both equal 1
7th so it checks out let's do a more
involved one
let's do a more involved problem so
let's say i had this was pretty involved
right here let's say i have
negative x
over
x
minus 2
plus
i'm going to give it some space here 3
x minus 1 over x plus 4
is equal to
1 over 1 over
x squared plus 2 x
minus 8.
so once again if we want to get rid of
all of these x terms we need them we or
in the denominator we want to multiply
essentially by the least common multiple
the least common multiple of this
expression this expression and this
expression but this one looks like it
can be factored so maybe it already has
some of these guys in it so let's let's
try to figure that out
so this right here this is what this is
x
plus 4
times x minus 2. so it does indeed have
both of these in it so let's multiply
both sides of this equation by
this thing or by x plus 4 and x minus 2.
so if we multiply it so this thing it
can just be rewritten as that so i just
did that let's multiply both sides of
the equation by that so let's see
we're going to multiply by x plus four
times x minus two if we do it on the
right hand side we have to do it on the
left hand side
scoot over a little bit so this term i'm
gonna have to multiply by x plus four
times x minus two same thing for this
term that's why i left some space x plus
four
times x minus two i'm just multiplying
every term in this equation by this
right there
now on the left hand side what do we get
this x minus 2 cancels with this x minus
2. we have nothing left in the
denominator this term right here
will become negative x
negative x
times x plus 4.
that's that term right there
now this term and this term right here
this x plus 4 will cancel with that x
plus 4. so we're left with
we're left with plus 3 x minus 1 times x
minus 2
and then the right hand side
the right hand side that cancels with
that that cancels with that and we
essentially multiplied both sides by
this denominator by the inverse of this
whole expression so we're just left with
this one
and now we have to simplify it or we
have to multiply things out so negative
x times negative x is negative x squared
negative x times 4 is minus 4 x
and then we have 3x times x is plus
three x squared three x times negative
two is minus six x negative one times x
is minus x
or negative x negative one times
negative two is plus
2 all of that's going to be equal to 1.
now let's add
the same degree terms
so we have a second degree term and a
second degree term 3x squared minus x
squared that gives us 2
x squared
then you have a negative 4x a negative
6x and a negative x so what is that
going to be equal to negative 4 and
negative 6 is negative 10
minus another one is a negative 11x
negative 11x
and then finally we just have that
constant term out here plus 2
is equal to 1.
and let me show i got all the terms i
got all the terms now we could subtract
1 from both sides we could subtract one
from both sides
and the equation becomes
two x squared minus eleven x
plus one is equal to zero so it just
becomes a straight up traditional
quadratic equation and if we're just
looking for the roots we set it equal to
zero we're just looking for the x's that
satisfy this we can use the quadratic
formula
so the solutions are x is going to be
equal to negative b b is negative 11. so
negative negative 11 is positive 11 plus
or minus the square root
of b squared negative 11 squared is 121
minus 4 times a which is 2
times c which is 1
all of that
all of that over 2 times a all of that
over
4. so x is equal to 11 plus or minus the
square root of
4 times 2 times 1 is 8.
so 121
minus
8. so what is that that's 113
is that right square root of 100
third
all of that
over
4. i don't know can i factor 113 at all
did i get that right 4 times 2 times 1.
yeah that looks right so let's get our
calculator out to factory figure out
what these values are
so let me see so
let me just
so we want
we want to turn the calculator on
so go to my mean screen
and we want the square root the square
root of 121
minus 8.
10.63
so this is equal to
11 plus or minus 10.63
over
4. those are our two answers and if we
want to find the particular answers it
would be 11 plus
10.63
over 4 which would be what that would be
21.63 over 4. we could try to calculate
that in a second and then if you
subtract it 11 minus 10.63
is
11 minus 10.63
over 4 this is equal to what like .37
0.37 over 4 if i'm doing my math
correctly
so what do we get
what do we get so let's see 11 21.6
divided by 4 is 5.41
so this is equal to 5.41
and then the other solution
the other solution 0.37 divided by 4 is
going to be like .09 something so let me
so then we have the other solution is
the other solution is
11. well let me just do it 11 minus
10.63
yep we got our 0.37 divided by 4
is equal to
0.0925
so this is equal to
zero point
oh
0.0925
so i lost some precision this isn't the
exact because this wasn't 10.63 or 6301
it just kept going it's an irrational
number but this should get close so
let's check let's verify that these
actually work so let's try the 5.41
solution first
so if this is true
if this is true if we take
so let me let me put
5.4 let me just do it so if we do
so we're going to start off with 5.41 so
our original equation was negative x so
negative 5.41
divided by x minus 2. so 5.41 minus 2 is
3.41
so that's that term and then we have
plus
times 5.41
3 times 5.41 minus 1
divided by
5.41 plus 4 is 9.41
9.41
so the left-hand side
the left-hand side gives us 0 of 0.0319
so that's what the left-hand side equals
and let's see what the right-hand side
equals when we substitute x equal 5.41
and of course we've lost some precision
here we've lost some of the zeros but we
should get pretty close so the right
hand side if we take
1 divided by
5.41
squared
plus
2 times 5.41
plus this is a minus 8 i think i lost
that that's a negative 8 right there so
minus 8
minus eight
that is
that and they are very very very close
at least up to three digits 0.31
so it does work out and these other
things that they don't equal past that
because we weren't precise enough if we
were if we added the trailing zeros here
when we took the square root of 113 we
would have gotten the right answer if
you actually kept it in this form you
would have gotten the exact right answer
and so i'll leave it up to you to verify
that this is also another solution
but hopefully you found that
slightly instructive